guillaume genton le podium j'en ai un si
les manguiers aux jeunes gens tombent
d'accord adore les filles qui font de la
télé réalité contraire à son tableau de
chasse plusieurs stars du genre
ouais c'est moche ce dernier prit sa pas
du tout écrit ça alors déjà delphine ne
fait pas de télé réalité non ensuite et
je rappelle que guillaume genton c'est
un gentleman la pac tableau de chasse si
leur exactement bravo exactement non et
j'ai eu une histoire et quelques années
avec eux et qu'ils
n'ont non mais l'aurait on va pas avoir
des problèmes tous les soirs c'est bon
c'est bon esprit alors donc si vous avez
une malle à une très belle histoire est
l'histoire d'un mec de courtrai qu'un le
connaît oui oui vous me connaissez que
je connais moins en version wii que
j'aime bien je sais
on s'est passé et oubliez pas que
certains tabous ici et donc elle a fait
de la télé réalité oui bien longtemps et
annoncé en marine à la folie la télé
tout court brune aussi en basse et ben
voilà c'est vous bon bah sinon à
l'habitat story
c'est afida turner
elle est magnifique non alors non bon
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup je
sais moi aussi mais c'est la wii mais
les mecs je connais toute la vidéo
aujourd'hui quoi vous croyez vous êtes
fou quoi il est avec moi c'était des
coups sur lui
alors je vois la news bravo
félicitations si vous êtes faire mourir
les témoins des tirs ont un peu ouest
dont six mois commencez
à wells et dusty six mois avec une star
de télé réalité c'est beau c'est beau si
c'est une star c'est une star c'est une
vraie c'est pas genre à la fée non non
non c'est pas genre
mathilde desanges
12h non c'est vraiment c'est quelqu'un
de très très très connu c'est une des
plus connues énoncées une des plus
connues ouais ouais on peut pas de
relation donne le prénom et caméscopes
navire il veut pas dire mais c'est une
des plus connues nadal a fait ça la fait
salle était connu pour ça mais je ne me
rappelle pas la même version non mais
les mecs c'est comme si tu dis nagui tu
sais qui c'est tout de suite oui bah
voilà
vite avalé sa mère
[Applaudissements]
ap
mais qui a balancé sa cause et brême
s'est hélas je sais pas mais je m'en
faisais castany alors jamais alors ben
là jamais ce moment sur personne
d'accord merci surtout soigner s'il vous
plaît
à chaque fois qu'un invité bien pour un
livre les chroniqueurs se bat pour ne
pas avoir à le lire pas une grosse poule
non mais c'est vrai donc voilà qui me
délivre ici
gasperin oui d'accord mais c'est faux
j'irai me suis dit un livre j'arrête pas
marc est un peu d'invités talus à niveau
de poser moins de questions sera mec
qu'a pas libre citi va déjà mieux oui le
vôtre et dans le coffre de la voiture
figurez vous ah oui en attente on attend
on attend de finir les livraisons je me
suis tout de suite allé dire toi là ce
week end là d'accord nous sommes
interrogés interrégional hébergé par à
la va-vite mathieu si mathieu a fait
toutes les émissions de la semaine au
lieu de deux habituellement c'est qu'il
a de gros problèmes financiers
[Rires]
ces poulets poutine
vraiment là
[Applaudissements]
elle réalise
qu'il y en a mais c'est rien c'est
vraiment ça ça en plus a brillamment
contre ça que j'ai demandé des pros ce
matin fait un parcours j'ai besoin
d'argent alors êtes vous savez on tourne
mal non mais non mais vraiment mais
vraiment pas y'a pas de mal alors les
chéris c'était chaud isabelle a fait des
compliments valérie sur son livre alors
qu'en réalité elle ne l'a jamais vu
comme beaucoup d'autres chroniqueurs
d'ailleurs vous l'avez échappé qu'ils
elle l'a lu mais elle ne l'a pas bien
d'autres elle ne l'a jamais lu on a même
tout je vous dis on a des preuves je
vous poser de questions sur les ovales
est restée voire six voies d'accès ou
quand il faisait apprendre par coeur
saddam et les comprendre oui dans son
livre valérie parle de deux peintres
qu'elle adore qui ça je ne sais plus là
là c'est pas les miens je sais que c'est
pas les mêmes que les miens sagement
souplesse ou blesser d'autres s'en sont
bien plus faciles ou l'achat basquiat
pas l'annoncer à son succès d alors
deuxième question de quel type de romans
valérie bénaïm et être tombée amoureuse
récemment c'est écrit dans son bouquin
moi tu l'a pas lu
son livre il est pas récent
valérie non dit la vérité est ce que
vous pensez qu'elle a lu votre livre
elles sont à la fac et mareth valérie
dit la vérité à la voiture fromage
arrête
tamoil
à la fac est affecté aux légumes arrête
un peu j'en rigolais arrête un peu dit
la mairie à la palud
je ne sais à la beauté je lis pas
attentivement un simple piano par
s'était pas sur la beauté donc c'est que
tu n'as pas lu
c'est pas grave car cela lui est sorti
du bois produit du shérif
de l'ormeau pense que benjamin castaldi
n'est pas un chroniqueur essentiel et
qui pourrait se faire oublier du public
en seulement quinze jours mais je vous
jure que je n'ai jamais dit celle qui a
été commencé
mais il dit ça tous les soirs là c'est
moi qui ai balancé non c'est pas moi
mais tous les soirs a lancé vous allez
lille ça aurait pu être moi
[Rires]
j'avais besoin de raconter mais j'ai
jamais dit ça cool dit jamais
d'aider d'autres coûts qui faisait que
vous adorez ça on est en direct pour se
faire bien voir guillaume lance de
fausses invitations chroniqueur pour
assister à des matchs du parc des
princes ouais mais une fois qu'ils ont
dit ok il répond désolé mais c'est trop
tard
c'est vrai ça aussi gilles verdez alors
ça c'est moi qui ai balancé quid alors
du poids et a que vous qui balançait
alors oui c'est moi c'était pays ma vie
de gentiment mais elle me dit écoute je
viens tu devrais venir avec fatou j'ai
deux places pour toi en loge vip au parc
des princes maintenir les jeunes mais là
je veux pas donc à la rentrée vient le
voir je suis dit écoute guillaume merci
de temps l'invitation c'est génial le
prochain match on est dispo et là il dit
à des infos sur miss france alors je dis
mais qu'est ce tu veux qu'ils se donnent
comme infos sur nice et j'en ai g2
naciri tu as des infos sur quesada tas
d'infos sur machin c'est en fait j'ai
dit mais j'ai pas d'infos et me dit pas
d'un faux pas classé
[Applaudissements]
il a fait un bon stage spécial je la
méritais une école c'est gratos espèces
de rats
serpents vigiles bravo tout inviterait
au prochain match à
benjamin
pense qu'il est bien meilleur animateur
que cyril à chaque fois des missions il
dit aux équipes moi j'aurais pas fait
comme ça alors ça c'est entièrement
alors alors ça je voulais ce sont les
équipes de tf1 d'oreillons qui me l'ont
dit que jurer sur la table et c'est pas
comme mais abaissé celle de
savoir si les gens ont déjà pris une
honnête souple est aujourd'hui entendu
cette rumeur mathieu alors non seulement
j'ai déjà entendu oui mais il y
également aussi il est pas là pour je
n'ai pas en eux se défendre le pauvre
qu'il est bien meilleur animateur que
montiel fait de quitter mais voilà il
dit sa version vos noms mais sur bernard
oui mais ça c'est mes lacets mes équipes
de production delphine oui effectivement
j'ai déjà entendu ça au maquillage si
c'est vrai parce qu'il fait des dépôts
riches peu après et toi merci la veille
c'est vrai nom il fait des débrief des
émissions de la veille en disant oui
c'est vrai
il a dit si à dix sages rappellent alors
monsieur played en attendant vous
défendra après yom chantons dans ses
bras il dit toujours voulu être le
meilleur animateur c'est vrai mais là
dit il s'est confié à moi oui mais voilà
ces curés moi je ne dis pas
we have you been importe quoi dallas est
sûre
même pas que camembert c'est que les
fromages sont souvent communs elle perd
la boule
pas du tout la boule il s'appelle vous
avez très bien raisonné vire indique
maël vous admire il est subjugué les
sous emprise la peur aussi bol d'or
n'est pas en jeu pas non plus non mais
faut pas dérivé de google ou plus
nombreux on dit la vérité oui on
s'appelle parfois avec benjamin en
débrief et c'est vrai que parfois on dit
avec bungie c'est un peu long là on aura
dix heures plus court là on a déconné on
n'aura pas fait comme ça moi mais moi je
lui dis moi il manquait un peu de rythme
dans l'émission une belle carrière comme
la vôtre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que je ne la franchit il n'importe
quoi
la vérité c'est mon ami
jamie
dimon dit la vérité devant ma grille
fondé avec la raison a imagé même
débrief avec géraldine sur des missions
difficiles manque de rythme et j'étais
chez moi donc nourrir et avant-hier j'ai
vu j'ai vu qu'il manquait du real
aintenant il ya beaucoup de rires
isabelle alors moi ils ne venaient
jamais rien entendu tête ce qui prouve
qu'une définitivement qu'il ne me parle
pas et donc quand tu es bon tu en penses
[Applaudissements]
j'ai merdé c'est pas moi qui ai balancé
mais j'aurais pu
tous les soirs et que ça démarre sa les
deux boxeurs pressez l'ail un couloir
derrière
si je suis là quand je marche vite aussi
et il me dit cyril était pas bon encore
une nuit et où je suis bien meilleur
pourquoi je présente pas et au génie
mais ça fait 20 ans que tu es nul il est
mais non c'est pas possible c'est ça
c'est sa porte
c'est alors c'est tout cas je vous dirai
je ne veux même pas le sable la sicile
mais c'est important et ça je sais ce
que vous veniez quel homme il arrive
quelque chose je vous jure ce serait le
plus cher au monde même génial moi je
vous crois que j'aimerais leyrit non
mais j'ai reparlé de vous essayer aux
allait bouleverser les producteurs vous
avez fait une heure et une heure
quarante-cinq d'improvisation je suis
arabe ce jeu le maire a les cheveux je
peux terminer benjamin je le sais mais
non mais je trouve que là c'est des gens
qui veulent faire les givrés moi c'est
vous bande pas raison mais bon dos rond
de cuir
[Rires]
entière angie je ne crois pas un instant
non je le disais tu es meilleur que moi
c'est en dessous dans la gradation alors
me suis citadine c'est vrai mais ça
perso je vous retrouve très jeune et
déjà dis pas ce que je fais pas tu l'as
dit ok je vous l'avais dit la joie des
promeneurs sur l'a61
sur ses craintes touristes et le
meilleur je vous dise qu'il est mort
c'est clair j'ai inventé un genre je
vous ai
dit non un genre d'animation il se place
au bajaur est ce que je voulais déjà dit
ou pensé vrai c'est vrai faire le voyage
unis d'amérique ça m'agace mais on est
encore sur vous c'est décidément à
castanet a déjà volé des blousons que le
stylisme avait prêté à raymond oui c'est
vrai ça alors c'est vrai parce que enfin
en fin de saison les isérois bien ça va
mais j'étais pas bien je me cherchais
dans je me cherchais intellectuellement
et surtout physiquement et vu qu'il a et
qu'il a une grande taille j'ai été
obligée du grand de cesser ses besoins
voilà c'est vrai et je les ai bien
ramener mercantilisme le film des
blousons à raymond lui prêtent vraiment
les vols
il se l'est fait voler c'est vrai
j'avais j'avais été essayées des
malheurs et de chaînes pour qui la jeune
annie pas parce que je ne la cautionne
pas quoi c'est matthieu delormeau la
source est là c'est vous qui allez là
dire je
[Rires]
ne vous ai
pas dit de combien
ah ouais c'est la vente super
c'est pas la source
[Rires]
n est pas de moi
je pense que tu veux manger
c'est
une immense connerie
c'est certainement
est certainement faux et c'est quoi au
pire au hms roule et pour les
abonnements une zone
[Rires]
à l'é match l'animateur aller
à temps pour faire est une férue
tout ça pour ça
[Applaudissements]
cette base est l'enjeu
j'avais même pendant ses émissions comme
un dieu normaux je la connais depuis des
années
si ses cheveux la porte une chemise
d'ailleurs
ouvert
non
merci l aîné des vrais
atouts sont pas une autre
raymond est celui qui s'intègre le mois
la brande ils ne parlent à personne
était sa diva un chroniqueur anonyme
mais qui alors j'ai vraiment senti
choqué c'est lui qui parle plus on aime
aussi le mail alors là ça c'est
l'hallali c'était la connerie c'est le
mec qui reste le plus fort les loges
mais les gens qui parlent de soi tu veux
rentrer chez moi ils et d'emballage il
va me parler j'en peux plus je voudrais
c'est moi qui me lève le plus tôt s'est
jeté sur plus
souple et tous les sens benjamin
castaldi passe des essais pour faire de
la radio sur chérie fm et tous les gens
il recadre poliment
c'est vrai
ça tire à balles réelles
alors alors alors c'est entièrement faux
tu l'as fait deux fois les faits une
foire est menteur tu as fait tu l'as
fait pour de radiothérapie pour rfm
aussi non pas du tout même bitumée arrêt
tgv pour chérie fm qu'il voulait mais
prévenu avant et non non non non pas
elle toutefois pas prévu avant quand je
te les 10 et tu m'as dit comment tu as
fait pour le savoir on arrive à ce
niveau c'est possible c'est quoi si
exactement il a fréquenté koh lanta dans
les arbres exactement il m'a dit et il
m'a dit je lui ai dit et il m'a dit
comment tu as fait pour le savoir mais
j'allais te le dire c'est possible c'est
possible et j'ai d'autres outils qui
sont là
des maris cette deuxième session avec
cette pige il à cette adresse excusez
moi
on était plus sur une boutique on vous
concernant par exemple une double haie
il me semble il me semble une nouvelel
et c'est plus dur à digérer concrètement
prendre les gens pour des cons
condamnerait question qu'on se pose
quand même alors je vous dis rien
remarqué quoi là j'y
vois là bas me concerne oui oui alors
allez-y on voit des concerts allez-y
alors je je je je comprends pas vous me
comprenez
par
cette masse car
sur ce chroniqueur anonyme non pas du
tout à fait anonyme on est nous deux
voilà on persiste et c'est dur chômeurs
cyril cyril susnommé cyril hanouna
menace par menace les chroniqueurs de ne
pas les faire rentrer sur le plateau
s'ils n'achètent pas son livre
et il ne s'en tient pas qu'à ses
chroniqueurs il menace également ses
amis très proches ses collaborateurs
alors là c'est trop j'ai vraiment à ce
que sage avec l'ogc nice
la calomnie merci mais jamais il m'a dit
tu rentres pas si tu achète pas mon
exactement je vais faire des c honteux
c'est long trois
[Applaudissements]
matches mais c'est la charia oui
sébastien chanter moi
je fais ça non je vais rétablir la
vérité d'ailleurs si elle est très
fraîche puisque ça s'est passé tout à
l'heure vers 109 milliards heureusement
que vous êtes venu chez tous les
chroniqueurs effectivement pour demander
si on avait lu le livre mais de manière
très sympathique alors moi à mon tour je
vous ai répondu non non non c'est bien
monsieur et messieurs et voilà on a dit
qu'on allait liant moi s'il me rabaisse
cheminant c'est super bizarrement il ya
là trois épreuves en tout cas
d'injection
exceptions comme ça qu'on dit gestion
diction direction de l'école est venu
isabelle saporta ici elle est venue une
autre fois elle a donné des livres
athlètes
là ça je vous aime être là comme tanné
d'être ici c'est pour démonter à
l'onatra tout le temps avec vous mais là
c'est l'endettement
a offert très gentiment des livres à
l'insu de cyril hanouna s'ils le
savaient
vous n'étiez pas contrôler ses nerfs
suffisamment parlé les salariés régime
de témoin monsieur à venir ian caple
bien établie les chatons ils sont tout
petits
ils sont derrière le
chalet ne même pas avoir derrière
[Applaudissements]
déjà je ne connais pas assez de
personnel je n'ai pas envie de connaître
bas des rêves je vous dire puisque vous
le prenez comme ça un suicide à partir
de maintenant oui oui il existe pas
sanitaire en ce moment mais pour vous
béda hymne et castaldi je lance le pass
amazon
vous allez devoir montrer votre pass
hamas
j'en oublie
[Musique]
mais chez moi de la changer on est deux
qui croient à leurs histoires et
personnages sont appelés république est
sûre à leur histoire
est ce qu'on peut faire un plan sur le
public personne n'a levé la main mais
personne n'a levé la main pour vous je
vois le public croyait bien entendu est
ce que vous pourriez à l'histoire de
bénéfices me jean personne n'y croit ce
que vous croyez à mon histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa bulle
et je ne veux qu'ils sachent que dans de
nombreuses et de nombreuses années
s'agirait d'aller mieux vous enfoncez
pas est mon ami j'aimerais pas utiliser
la matinée et une admission de
l'intérieur n'avait jamais manqué
isabelle et jean marc léger mieux que
vous n'avez jamais
pourriez-vous donc dire face caméra
les yeux dans les yeux pas la cas usac
oui mais la voilà hanouna que je connais
l'homme intègre droit l'article donc
oui tu ne pourrais pas faire sa
chronique demain s'il ne venait pas avec
son téléphone la septante d'écran de son
achat sur amazon touché par les deux
passionnés de passe de passer à basse
amazon il faut qu'on vous dise pour
l'heure on a des accusations très cher
et c'est déjà 6 h à cette règle ça sort
bien et vous dites n'importe quoi
c'était là mais ses yeux dans les yeux
vous êtes une menteuse et vous castaldi
vous êtes manipulés par la meinau
du coup
j'avais remarqué c'est vous que gilles
verdez a dit à beinheim les yeux dans
les yeux à castaldi n'a pas dit les yeux
dans les yeux
comme nous alors barça c'est vrai que
senna qui saigne et non j'ai pas lui
dire gérard baudoux moi qui vais acheter
qu'elle ticket de caisse pour tomber est
ce que vous pouvez me donner un bonus un
jour où serait très en colère contre moi
allez allez
ces combats c'est dommage
il s'appelle savard clos fin mai
c'est fou la baroche d un autre cas pour
moi aussi je mets en place le pass
amazon
mais sur amazon les chérissait les
libraires chérie je note qu'il a pas
beaucoup parlé tu as dit on est deux à
avoir une peau qui je note que me balan
et vol a été prêté sélection féminine
enfin
est ce que est ce que benjamin arrêter
les hors vraiment est ce que te laisse
pas
je reste totalement solidaire et en plus
sa route que vous êtes noir et à les
vendre ne feront l'équipe ou 18 euros
sur amazon ou un stock offerte par le
militaire vous avez un stock que vous
gardez précieusement chez vous à
castaldi oui
je vous reposer la question une dernière
fois les caisses qui a est ce que vous
comptez rester oui aux côtés de bénabar
le seul chérit tant d'amitié monsieur
star 10 ans 20 ans l'approché des
prochaines années ce sera 20 ans de pôle
emploi
[Applaudissements]
que d'une voiture par le virus en mai
montre en mer des cordes alors vous ne
ferez pas dire et je ne veux dire jamais
les gens les gens je vous dis sur des
choses hors antenne vous avez voulu
mentir ce qui s'est passé en wendel
c'est votre choix moi j'ai delphine qui
est avec moi delphine a vu toute la
scène on est en loge maquillage whissell
fine je sais que vous êtes extrêmement
honnête tel film merci merci ca peut se
demander si c'est vrai heureusement
c'était la cible des fans du genre
foulée des vidanges nous on fait des
vidanges
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mort à la guerre
parce que parce que vous or tant de
georges et déambule vous vous avez vous
c'est un effort parce que vous avez fait
ça sur la confiance que vous avez en moi
delphine assisté à la scène mais c'est
encore plus fort voilà c'est encore plus
fort j'ai emmené sans pense de sa
d'accord avec vous je croise en bourse
il est dépressif
et chérif dans ses yeux je vois dans le
coeur des
défilés je vois le sol et je vois le
score intel c'est insupportable
les séries quand vous le savez dans ce
joli c'est poutine et
delphine la population je vais me
tourner vers rare parce que là a fait
parler d'un dossier épineux à 19h50 en
direct sur ces 8 c'est le dossier
delphine wespiser destine que je protège
tant que je peux a beau tient
dit la vérité et je te protège toujours
sur mes chaumergy ce titre parce que
vous m'avez dit un jour que j'étais pur
et c'est vrai pur
tromper
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
faudrait pas qu'on a tous eu très peur
vous n'êtes pas bon tu sais très bien
renseignés c'est peut-être la fin de
l'émission
c'est peut-être la fin d'une histoire
c'est pas ta ta fatigue se fait vite on
termine alors mes séries jeudi qu'elle
était très pure et j'ai une confiance
aveugle en est sûrs c'est moi elle filme
des crimes quoi il faut rétablir jeu
mais chavez devant mais jure établir
plein de vérité oui delphine vous avez
été draguée et je le dis aujourd'hui je
vais tout balancer vous avez été draguée
autour de cette table parier aujourd'hui
si dieu pas nous a pas caché je sais que
maintenant voilà aujourd'hui tu as well
as d'autres
techniques ça
mais c'est vrai pour lui la coupe est
pleine ça y est tu peux pas sauter et
été draguée par guillaume jours
d'ailleurs il m'a invité aussi un macho
encore un match de foot et c'était sans
rien en échange
bien sûr juste essayer d'empêcher
sentiment aussi très pur l'un envers
l'autre alors je vais te dire ce qu'est
la pureté de l'eau
très fine tu as été draguée là je vais
je vais dévoiler tous les gens qui ont
dragué défini et vous allez voir il ya
des surprises non mais les mecs c'est ça
ma fait froid dans le dos de près ou de
loin j'ai vraiment fait un panel globale
comme ça c'est comme ça on normal oui je
sais
non mais à la fin le modèle global est
la raison qui qui va bien sûr mais je
quitte qui tibaoui à jon hamm aveugle
mais vous s'il vous plaît casta les
gens me oudin ragués oui bien sûr shalma
visible et tout le monde l'a vu c'était
plus d'heureux il ya à peu près deux ans
mais très visible même à l'antenne donc
d'accord très bien voilà raymond vous a
dragué si si quand les réseaux sociaux
elle n'avait pas lui même a essayé un
peu quand on envoie l'abricot une
auberge et heureuse
c'est pas qu'on vous invite à faire le
match et
c'était brevet c'est vrai c'était au
long cours et
alors c'est très spécial ça fait que
mathieu voilà un père aimant vosges à
paris tu sais tu es pajama castaldi
s'était fait qu' il y avait un tel
lancement de quelque chose sont dorées
du tout
arrêtez-vous cassady arrêté s'il excède
parler s'il vous plaît delphine et je
devine je dirais ma vérité sur castaldi
d'accord et je compte sur vous alors
vous pouvez avec sommeil mittal heures
[Applaudissements]
jeannot castaldi c'est ce soir vous
dormez chez vous une coupe une couille
et
ça nous regarde non mais reconnaît
georges est déjà fermé la porte la roue
est la tournée vite
[Rires]
c'est il ya deux ans il ya presque
prescription a franchement non on va pas
au fond vous et pour sa femme beaucoup
moins
alors c'était en laponie et c'est vrai
qu'on s'entendait bien benjamin c'est
vrai mais pas du tout
mais je parle pas de je parle on
s'entendait très bien regarde bien non
je peux pas la garder
regardez un déclic après la laponie mais
alors sinon la laponie vous faire sortir
maintenant il ne me regardent plus mais
effectivement en laponie on s'entendait
bien on se taquinait bien même nom mais
là on la fois dire que si ma volée un
chausson c'est aussi en courant je lui
ai couru après et après l'été alors
c'est vraiment la forêt
h et a coupé mon jeu c'est me rappelle
très bien
joué je sentais les choses ça sert mais
c'est dans ces moments là était en est
et ak on était très marrant que certain
regard peu ça sera oui ou non mais voilà
je vois quand on côtoie le chausson sais
pas draguer si
on coupe pas mes chaussures tous les
jours mais
est donc ensuite c'est la fameuse nuit
en question avait dit
la vidéo les jeux de mots des gringos je
me sens il doit une pub je reste avec
nous ou trop il n'y a rien de grave mais
pour beaucoup comme un muscle et moi
c'est bien s'il vous plaît arrêter alors
à jama est ce que vous avez en prévision
un prochain mariage
[Rires]
cette nuit c'est donc vous avez dormi
ensemble alors à 4 heures je m'appelle
dehors mais ça devrait donc la turballe
donc là il y est toujours éveillé
c'est vrai il devait être 19h mais il
faisait vraiment bien nuit et donc vous
avez dit qu'on ferait une soirée plus ou
moins pyjama tous ensemble moi je fais
la queue tout seul voilà ce qui
d'ailleurs ne s'est jamais fait en voilà
alors et alors vous avez dit il faut que
delphine parce qu'elle va manque de
chambres à y dormir chez benjamin et
c'était pour une séquence télé en plus
ce que j'ai fait puisque je suis très
bon élève et que je veux j'ai couvert
c'est pas du tout ça c'est compter la
tire au sort qui dorment avec oui
ça y est vous étiez encore lorsque vous
êtes arrivé après et moi j'ai pas ma
chambre et alors on a 10 bat delphine
helle de rock qui pour la séquence télé
bim bim bim elle arrive dans une chambre
ce que j'ai fait si du coup je suis
arrivé dans la chambre et et voilà et
donc il y avait il y avait deux il y
avait deux lits y avait 2 et via un
canal voilà et donc du coup bah moi
j'étais dans ma chambre j'ai des coups
tirés il a dit qu'il fallait aller dans
la chambre et voilà
et
jeudi c'est cool parce qu'en plus sain
pour faire connaissance parce que je
pensais qu'ils avaient il y avait alors
il y avait une amie delphine ans pétri
garçon manqué alors là d'un poil manque
envoyer une photo où elle dormait avec
un pote à elle
c'est parce qu'elle dort avec des potes
non mais il avait réveillé pas de mal
mais non merci s'il n'y a pas de marge
mais quel site du coup moi guillaume
c'est son pote sinon
et donc l'embellie est donc vous sirène
avait quand même très longue histoire
alors et donc israël et s'est endormi et
castaldi s'est endormi je suis parti et
depuis il ne me parle plus rejoué après
je lui dirai pourquoi tu me parles plus
oui mais ma femme elle a pris un truc je
sais pas quoi de laponie et du coup elle
veut plus que je te parle elle a lancé
sa carrière
oui
nous y sommes voilà
ça tire à balle mais voilà c'est bon
c'est bon ça tu dois t'en l'accomplir
voilà ça ne veut plus fous par delphine
et pas du tout mais si à rennes et
l'hôpital mais elle a eu vent d'une
histoire en laponie bola
benzema cette histoire je veux la vie
d'une seule et unique personne de qui il
est en colère ok ça et là ce soir qui
rogers texan coeur l'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'en est rien
francoeur
moteur moins chez nous comme ça qu'on
doit bien ça s'est bien rendu à regarder
c'est mon roger damour
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui ah oui ah oui
sa maman routeur bonsoir à tous
c'est une surprise pour dati ne s'est
pas arrêté là mais oui mais j'ai pressé
l'armée était venue plomber nous
c'est mon job est alors des coups alors
voiture pas voir que tout le monde
branche tama fouet alors je sais que tu
as une grande confiance en elle et c'est
ça qui est beau et c'est vrai que tu
peux avoir confiance en delphine je peux
te dire j'ai confiance mais ça n'empêche
pas le contrôle ah oui c'est ça ouais
donc dans ma lointaine alsace j'ai les
oreilles qui sifflent terme et donc il
ya des moments franchement j'entends
ce soir que delphine est en couple
[Rires]
photo c
bien sûr j'avais vu des photos sur je
pensais que c'était un ami de son père
alors est-ce qu'on peut commencer bien
sûr lui qui me déçoit le plus c'est moi
pas les attaquer un pays il est
d'origine d'alsace hockey y est ils
l'invitent delphine à manger chaque fois
jean-jacques des petits sms
n'aurait-on mais qui
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé c'était mon frère
s'entendent très bien à chaque fois oui
mais oui je suis et j'ai que de place
dans la voiture
non mais des fois je suis très très très
con après je suis qui m'a pas déçu du
tout c'est mathieu
[Rires]
et et puis l'histoire de laponie amène
alors que jamin benjamin franchement m'a
déçu quand je suis arrivé ici à trois
ans avec delphine c'est la première
personne connue avec qui j'ai fait un
selphy une photo dallas est une
célébrité et là ils l'ont bois ils
envoient des messages tout ça j'ai dit à
delphine del si tu peux pas avoir un
truc avec ce mec on a ces dettes c'est
bon
[Rires]
vendée
pouvait pas gaz et
des gaz et un bain et voilà je vous dise
pourquoi on a mis delphine au plus bas
on attire aussi en rester là et on s'est
retrouvé dans la chambre avec malaga
c'est sûr benjamin castaldi un problème
de gaz si c'est vrai
c'est vrai surtout à la capap et ratures
en laponie tous quevedo froid dehors
était chaud à l'intérieur
et donc voilà je voudrais dire que
rogers et la soif différé des abris et
il prend ça vraiment avec le soutien sûr
qu'ils jouent à des jeux j'aime vraiment
ce rythme c'est mon job je voulais tout
réussir et je veux dire le droit de la
souris singing get well soon yi gang est
maintenant fait plus de blé abanico on
n'a fait qu'un jet donc n'allait pas aux
sunshine
[Applaudissements]
m
voilà
[Applaudissements]